so for those of you that don't know i am
in iceland right now i am playing the
reykjavik open
and actually just finished round one and
i'd like to do a
recap video the start of a new series
and i do know i still owe you guys one
more recap from gibraltar but because
i'll be focusing on the reykjavik
tournament for the next week or so
i'll be doing recap videos when i do
have the time
and i actually want to start this video
by sharing some photos
because i've been in iceland for the
last uh five or six days
and i've been doing some touristy things
and trying to adjust to the weather
the time zone
and uh and the horses
uh so a few days ago i had the pleasure
of riding an icelandic horse uh figured
this would be good preparation of
reviewing how the horsey moves
and uh also visited bobby fischer's
grave
bobby fischer is buried in a small town
in salfas iceland
and i actually visited in 2016
but
returned to pay some respects
and then
i played chess with a goat
um now this isn't the goat you would
imagine uh usually when we think of
chess goat we think of
fisher
carlson or kasparov but this was a real
goat
i tried eating the chess pieces
but uh thankfully i
i was able to hold on to all of my
pieces
and then i saw the northern lights um
which was really really cool this
picture i took uh with a 25 second
exposure
so this wasn't quite what it looked like
in real life
but uh when you allow a lot of light to
come into the camera
it can really accentuate the the lights
and uh it was definitely a bucket list
item to check off so uh let's get into
the game i was paired in round one
against uh another player from the usa
ryan murphy who i i do know actually
he's from wisconsin
and last time i saw him was in st louis
he was visiting i actually took a photo
of him
a few years ago in 2018 i was actually
at a uh
after party
featuring a lot of strong grand masters
and uh imagine a lot of people
recognized some of the grand masters in
this photo
but my opponent was a guy right here i'm
trying to use my cursor but it's not
capturing my cursor oh there we go
okay so i'm playing ryan murphy
who
has been in very close contact with
ikaru and fabiano and
a few other grand masters
and
yeah i did a little bit of preparation
for the game
and i found his old chess.com account
and i knew to expect a kerocon which did
happen after e4 and c6
and it took me a little bit of time to
decide what to play because i could have
gone for london or english already but i
figured i would test him in his main
opening
and i went for a sideline pawn d3
which i've played a few times before i
played against sagar shah in the
speedchest championship match also
played a maybe once or twice against
levy
in the same event
and d3 kind of signifies that white's
going for a king's indian attack salap
with knight d2 g3 bishop g2 knight f3
and this is basically what happened
after d5 knight d2
ryan chose a pretty solid line g6
and i go for
yeah basic king's indian attack g3 25
bishop g2 97 castling
castling we both played the moves pretty
quickly in the opening
and this isn't the most confrontational
opening but i decided to go for this
because
it's a position that just has a lot of
life and it's not something that
liquidates too quickly
and i actually had this position
on my computer screen about half hour
before the round began
and i prepared the move pawn a4
now the main line here is rook to e1
which
is an attempt to kind of pressure the
e-file threatening to take and then win
upon
but after pawn d4
black scores pretty well here
and pawn a4 is um a bit more flexible of
a move uh because there's cases where i
want to keep my rook on f1 in the event
that black plays d4 i can go for knight
c4 and then later pawn f4 ideas
so
after i played a4 ryan took kind of the
first think of the game and ultimately
decided to play a5
which is a very flexible move and i
played c3 still trying to stay flexible
and here the the main move for black is
to play knight a6
which intends to go for knight c5
and if black went for this then i'd
probably just place all the queen c2 uh
then decide whether to put the rook on
e1 or d1
but instead in the game uh ryan played
pawn h6
which was kind of a waiting move um i
think in hindsight this move was a
little bit slow
even though the intention is to prevent
knight g5 and to prepare bishop d6 we're
gonna see that white gets some
somewhat quick initiative
after rookie one i am threatening to
take on d5 and win the e pawn so black
has to do something about it
uh played rook e8
and now i keep initiative i take on d5
take
and knight c4
so now i have three attackers against
the pawn
and black is put into
some kind of decision moment
how to defend the pawn and there are a
few moves here
um now black doesn't really want to play
f6 this is just
being really mean to the bishop on g7
after f6 i would have d4 which would be
quite nice for white
uh during the game i was expecting
bishop g4 which i think was a better
choice uh just
pinning the knight and if h3 that can
trade
uh and if queen takes there's knight d7
and um i was expecting to go into
something like this now maybe not knight
g7 right away because i do have knight
d6 here
but i'll move like queen c7
and um the game would go on
uh instead
black played knight d7 here
and uh as we're gonna see the
bishop just got stuck on c8 and i was
still happy to go for the move d4
and because white has a slight lean
development
it makes sense for me to try and open
the position so after it takes we traded
rooks takes and i recapture on d4
and uh here the pawn structure is almost
completely symmetrical
if i had a pawn on h3 it would be
exactly symmetrical but there are a few
kind of imbalances
my knights are a little bit more active
and because the queen is on e8 i do have
ideas of knight to d6 to try and uh get
the bishop hair
and yeah here ryan took a bit of a think
and decided to play knight f6
um during the game i was thinking uh
like knight e5 or knight c5 or even
knight b6 these are all possible moves
but after knight f6 i
realized that i can just kind of calmly
complete development
now it's not easy to find a good square
for my bishop because the knight's
controlling
e3 and f4 and i can't develop to g5
obviously
but i played the move bishop d2
and
it was actually pretty simple uh plan
for white is to go for queen d3
and then rook to e1 to control the
e-file
now i should note i can't play queen b3
right away because after queen
to e1
i'd be in some trouble bishop f1 is met
with bishop to h3
so bishop d2 was a precise move order
and uh yeah we reached a position where
it just wasn't easy to find a clear plan
for black as if black tries to play a
similar move
i can start targeting the undefended b7
pawn with a move like queen b3
and then having ideas of knight e6 to
follow
along with rookie one and black is
clearly under a lot of pressure here
so instead uh ryan played a bit
creatively and went for the move between
f8
getting off the e file defending the
pawn another time
after i play queen b3
pawn h5 was played
and now it's clear that black has ideas
of either playing pawn h4
or bishop to h6
and
at first during the game i thought this
was a creative idea to uh maybe try and
trade a little bit try and weaken my
king side in some way
but the more i thought here the more i
realized i can kind of just ignore
what black is trying to do
and carry through with my own ideas
and i started with the move rookie one
just controlling the open e file
and after pawn h4 i just continued to
ignore black's play on the king side and
play the move knight to e5
uh just improving the knight
and now the development for white is
just really nice the knights are well
defended in the center
a bishop is pressuring d5 along with the
queen
and the queen is a line with the king so
there's some x-ray vision
against the king on g8 for example if
the knight ever moves if we play just a
dumb move knight c7 and then i'd have
knight takes g6 because of the pin on f
pawn
so in some sense the knight is pinned
along the diagonal
and we're going to see that black gets a
little bit paralyzed in in just a few
moves
now bishop h6 was played which is an
interesting attempt to trade bishops
and if i knew that black was going to go
for a bishop trade a few moves earlier
i would have been happy to basically
trade off my worst place piece in the
position the bishop on d2 but then i
realized here that
this bishop isn't so useful for black
either
and the general rule is that when you're
controlling more space and more center
you should avoid trains and minor pieces
just because you want to put the
opponent in a more crown position
and i decided here to play the move pawn
f4
just avoiding uh trades entirely
and also reinforcing the knight
and even though pawn f4 maybe looks a
little bit weakening at first uh moving
upon from my king there's no real way
for black to exploit the king in this
position and this kind of induced black
to go for the move queen c5
which looks active at first pinning my
knight
but it just invited the move bishop to
e3 which i was very happy to play
aligning with the queen
and now the queen is just regretting its
life decisions
and i should point out here the knight
on d5 is pinned
to the pawn on f7 so black has no time
to take on e3 because this is just
getting mated knight takes g6 would be
checkmate
so
what black had to do here is just
retreat the queen
all the way back to f8
now there was a funny line i was
thinking of during the game
it looks like black can try the move
knight g4
just to try and muddy the waters have
two attackers against the bishop
but this would walk into a really really
nice tactic
knight to e6
attacking the queen twice so basically
double check against the queen
now this move also obstructs a bishop
from defending the knight on g4
and this is relevant because after a
move like queen to d6 i can happily take
the knight
after it takes
take the bishop on h6 and white is just
up a piece at the end of this line
and
when i was calculating these variations
during the game
i was just getting really excited
thinking that
my experience from a few days ago
of riding the icelandic horse
would be very nice to include
in in the thumbnail photo because the
nylon e6
is a very majestic creature almost as
majestic as an icelandic horse
but sadly this didn't happen in the game
after bishop e3 queen f8 was played
and i decided to reposition the bishop
on f2 where black can't trade it off
and now the bishop is just really nicely
placed keeps my king safe
and after pawn h3 bishop f3 the bishop
now restricts any piece from coming to
g4 so there's no knight g4 there's no
bishop g4
and i was thinking during the game that
black is just really close to being
completely paralyzed it's almost
zugswang in this position
um very difficult to find a move for
black just because knight is still
essentially pinned along the diagonal if
knight ever moves there's still knight
takes g6
the bishop is completely locked out
this knight is tied down to defending
the nylon d5 the bishop is tied down to
defending the pawn in b7
and if the rook tries to move to b8 to
over defend the pawn then i have the
move knight takes c6
and i'm exploiting the pin on the b file
so
what ended up happening was
queen d6 was played
which looks like a logical
somewhat active move
but the problem with this move
is it walks into some tactics because it
leaves f7 undefended
and i have the very explosive move here
on c4
and it turns out that black is losing
material by force
and um
to my surprise
ryan actually resigned in this position
just didn't play on i should also note
that he had uh less than a minute left
when he did resign i was getting into
some very serious time trouble
um this is move 24 so it's still
somewhat early in the game
but to explain why c4 is just so deadly
is if the knight moves there's actually
probably a few tactics at win for white
but i was planning knight takes f7
exploiting the fact that after king
takes f7 there's pawn c5
with the discovered check and uh white
is just winning the queen here
and
uh basically wherever the knight moves
i'm gonna have the same tactic like if
knight c7
again i can take on f7 and i haven't
checked this game yet with engine i've
actually been doing this whole recap
with engine turned off
so i'm just gonna verify real quick
that yeah after pawn c4 this is
completely winning for white
and
all the top engine moves are uh are not
moving the knight like bishop g7 stop
moving
yeah any case white's winning
a lot of material and
resigning i guess was justified for
black
so overall i was pretty happy with the
game um i think it was a pretty clean
game on my part
and
afterwards i wasn't entirely sure
what the crucial mistake was from
black's perspective
it may have been
earlier in um
in the middle game
perhaps allowing
this line um
allowing takes in knight c4 maybe black
is already under a little bit of
pressure
uh i think during during the game i
thought black should really get the
knight to c5 as quickly as possible
but um yeah overall i
have no complaints about this game this
nice positional build up and i hope
there's a thing or two that viewers can
learn
from this game
and it was from an opening that i don't
really play too often it was a king's
indian attack against the cairo khan
but maybe after this game i'll have to
play this this whole thing more often if
it works as well
so uh that just about does it
if you want to follow the broadcast of
the tournament i will leave links in the
description uh this was played on a dgt
board so the game was broadcast live and
there is a live commentary uh from the
official tournament which i will also
link below
so uh yeah i'm gonna end it here thanks
for watching and stay tuned for more
recaps